you start training for like 10 plus  years [ __ ] just starts hurting because  of who you are this has been the best  fix I found and I've paid every  specialist in the [ __ ] planet so  you wrap up you don't want to flex your  bicep at all and what we're going to do  is we're going to hang and then breathe  and you'll breathe through your nose  [Music]  it stretches the living [ __ ] out of your  rib cage because like what happens is  when you train heavy like barbell  deadlift whatever if you look straight  down through a spine your rib cage  compresses this way so you become less  round which is better for training  because you're stronger but it's worse  for everything else your breathing comes  less efficient and then your movement  patterns get [ __ ] up so this  counteracts that it literally stretches  your rib cage back out so you breathe in  so you're stressed and then you feel the  spacer stretches the cartilage the other  way